hello everyone I definitely have to be
careful not to upload any games too fast
because like what happened in my
previous video I uploaded the video
everything was cool and when I started
watching the the coverage of the world
with championship I saw that the result
has in fact changed the arbiters
decision was overruled and cousin in
fact won that game against Inter Kiev so
this game here it's it's a game from
round 3 Carlson is playing against
ukrainian grandmaster uniquely Balducci
KO a very strong player his boots rating
is somewhere around 20 27 40 and he was
the 2013 Ukrainian champion so a very
strong player and it this game really
shows how how blitz can be merciless the
at one point critical doesn't really
find which way to go and he could have
actually saved the game but blitz like I
said is a merciless time control I will
let you find what you hear missed in the
game so Carlson has the white pieces and
this time he goes for d4 we have Knight
to f6 Bishop to f4 e 6 III and d5 Knight
to f3 c5 now c3 Knight to c6 and Knight
B to d2 Bishop to e7 Bishop to d3 by
Carlsen and the knight to h5 across and
plays Bishop to e5
we have f6 kicking the bishop back with
g3 and now g6 probably 2 to give this
knight and h5 some additional protection
as the Queen from d1 is x-raying it
Queen to d2 by Carlson and Bishop to d7
d captures on c5 we have Bishop captures
on c5 and E for now by Carlsen Knight
captures on g3 and we have H captures on
g3 and this is a pretty I mean it's a
pretty important decision do you want to
trade this night for this bishop this is
a very strong Bishop and all while it's
a very strong Bishop also it gives
additional protection to have to pawn
but while capturing it you give cross in
the open H file so it's a it's a very
hard decision to make in blitz d captors
on e4 bichri
Bishop characters and we have King to f7
Crossin castles Queen side and we have
Queen to c7 now night the c-4 rook to d8
and Queen to d2 pressuring that Bishop
on d7 also eyeing the h6 square so
cleaver root ball goes Bishop to c8
opens up an attack on call since Queen
and we have Queen to h6 rook captures
rook captures and King to g8 and thus
King to g8 it seems like a weird move
but you you really don't have a lot of
options here you can't develop this rug
because Queen captures eights and on h7
so cleavage go probably played King to
g8 with plans of going Queen to g7 at
some point
Carson plays g4 and we have Bishop
captures on f2 here Queen to g7 it could
be an idea but after Queen to h2 that
Queen rook and King are really just
clustered in there g5 is coming either
way so not not the best position for
white for black sorry
so after g4 Bishop captures an f2 was
played URI grabs upon and we have Bishop
captures on c6 now Carlsen eliminates
the defender of the e5 square B captures
on c6 and now g5 the idea of course is
cross and wants to capture pawn on f6
and threaten some IDs on g7 and here
this is definitely the critical moment
in the game the problem with f5 is that
it immediately creates a bad position
for black after f5 Knight comes to e5
and it's really hard to find a move for
black here you can't really move the
Queen otherwise you get a rope to d8 and
there's really there's really no move to
play here for black you have to play
Bishop to c5 so you can move the Queen
and after rook comes the d8 so you can
defend with Bishop to f8 but even this
isn't enough simply Knight captures an g
6h captures Queen captures with the
check after Queen blocks rook to d8
check bishop goes to f8 and now Knight
to e5 Queen captures Knight captures and
now your Bishop is attacked on c8 this
Bishop on f8 is attacked twice by the
rook
and the night also drug on HHS attacked
so white is easily winning this game
but after g5 Yuri didn't go for this
Yuri played Queen to f4 check King Tubby
one was played and now Queen captures
night on c4 here cousin played G
characters on f6 and in this position
eunuch Rivage go resigned to the game as
there is no defense against Queen to g7
checkmate you don't have this Queen to
b4 check but after King to a-1 there's
really nothing to play here you can't
even escape with the king if king f7
simply Queen g7 checking it and Queen to
e7 this is checkmate but there is this
one move after g5 could that cost and
played one move actually saves the game
for a crib Orozco and I will let you
pause the video if you if you would like
and try and find this move it's it's
quite a sneaky move but you know I
really enjoyed it so there I gave you
some time to consider will you pause for
those of you who have found the move
congratulations it's not an another too
obvious move to find but it shouldn't be
too hard the move Klitschko missed here
is actually Bishop to g3 after Bishop to
g3 you don't really have the option of
playing G captures and f6 because of
Bishop to a4 check this checks the king
also Forks the Queen so Carlson loses
the Queen and the game so probably after
Bishop to g3 you can't really make any
progress as white unless you play King
to be one after King to be one black can
now play f5 and now all is well d5
square is again protected by the bishop
and the Queen and there isn't an easy
way for for whites to make any progress
here black is perfectly fine in this
position but could miss this he went
into the variation I showed and after G
captures on f6 he resigned to the game
so a very nice one by Carson and a very
nice recovery after that unfortunate
inner cave gambit in round one I just
wanted to say it's not that I'm only
covering Carlson's games because I want
to only cover Carlsen games it's just
that it's the blitz and the
the official coverage only pretty much
covers crossings games it's it's I mean
the moves really go quickly and they
couldn't really ship the boards you know
no one would understand what's going on
on either of the boards so if any of you
know of any great game played in in
blitz please do share in the comments
use hashtag suggestion
I will check all the comments and I will
check the game that you suggest so
that's it I hope you enjoyed this game
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you all for watching
and I will see you soon probably with
another video from the world blitz
championship see you soon